and again wouldn't it be wonderful if we
could help politicians to say
what they really mean my next guest is
michael spicer he's a comedian
who's made his name pretending to be the
voice inside the heads of the world's
most powerful people
you might know him as the man in the
room next door
he is with us now hello to you
good morning hi hi hi now you've got a
new book out have you let's talk about
that straight off the bat
the secret political advisor tell us
about it
um well it's uh basically um uh
an accumulation of texts and emails
and um direct messages and whatsapp
messages
and newspaper cuttings all around the
last four years
because that kind of that seemed to be
uh from from the beginning of the
brexit result through to now um
just seemed to be like a perfect block
of time to sort of analyze
and pretend that this advisor was at the
heart of it all
is that the actual room that you're in
yeah it is the actual room i'm at the
other side of the sofa
[Laughter]
tell me where you came up with the idea
um oh sorry
a light's just gone off um where i came
up with the idea um
well basically um it was
a uh it was boris johnson
uh searching for um
um an answer to the question what do you
do to relax which i think
is is something we'd be able to answer
quite easily
really um but i
for him it was well should i tell the
truth or should i lie and he was just
basically wrestling with that
answer and i just thought wow you know
an advisor could easily be next door
panicking on his behalf uh indeed so was
that the bosses one when he makes buses
he makes model buses yeah that's right
yeah what do you do how do you actually
put it together i mean because it's
fantastic and i've been a big fan ever
since i saw the first one
on twitter but it must take an awful lot
of work because
i'm guessing you have to transcribe it
first and then you have to think about
what the advisor would be saying and
then you have to film it so it's not
easy to put together is it no
um the the first uh
time i did it it it um it was a bit of a
struggle trying to make it gel i suppose
but the fact is
i've been doing it for over a year now
and it feels
quite like an easy thing to do like you
like you know
what are the moments that will work
with with with certain politicians who
uh a new thing i can cut in there i can
say something funny here
um and it's uh
it's all about the the comedy timing and
the fact is that today's politicians
have great comedy timing
any in particular that you're thinking
of
oh you know i'm thinking of
how do you decide which ones i mean when
you see them is there a particular
interview that you watch and you think
yeah i'm gonna have a bit of that
yeah there there is that um uh it's it's
when it's when interviewers such as
such as yourself make make politicians
flounder because
they're they're they're being armed with
a certain amount
of statistics and uh facts
or perhaps not facts and um
and when an interviewer pulls them apart
they're lost at sea um and and that's
that's that's where i come in i i just
you know but they have basically written
half my sketch for me already i think
i've appeared once i think and that was
um when a politician didn't actually
appear
and um he was we don't necessarily need
to name names james cleverley
and he was in the shower instead wasn't
he with his suit on getting very wet
yeah yeah yes i i i wish i'd had uh
james cleverly look alike but
unfortunately it wasn't
wasn't available at the time but also
you did uh
richard bergen uh and i would have
uh i would have done your recent uh matt
hancock
because you know i know you like to get
him in virtually every week and
make him a complete fool and you know
i'm always there for that but
um my schedule was packed recently so i
wasn't able to do it uh
he was very i mean it was very funny he
he did uh
crack a smile when we were talking about
and i'm gonna have to whisper this again
just in case the kids
are listening when we're talking about
casual sex
yes yeah well that um i think he smiled
because he was
uh really really embarrassed i don't
think there was any kind of
uh i don't think matt hancock's i don't
think he's been relaxed for about a year
now
so yeah do you have any sympathy for our
politicians because you know they are
they're people who've gone they've gone
into politics in order to try to make a
difference and now they're having to
make life or death decisions on a daily
basis
yes um well no um i mean i
i how many of them are are in how many
of them how many of the people in the
cabinet right now
are there because of uh some sort of
moral duty some sort of desire to change
things
i don't think there are many but that's
just a personal view
um but uh i i think that if you put
yourself up on that
platform and you say things that could
be
um seen as being uh
um well let's just
let's just say if they're just lying or
if they're being hypocrites
then they're absolutely uh they're fair
game
and this is mostly with um uk
politicians that you
that you take the mickey out of them but
i mean you're an absolute international
superstar these days aren't you on the
late late show my goodness
yes oh yes i've just done one for the
for the late late show trump v
biden debate which i thought i wouldn't
be able to do frankly because
um trump could not be reined in he could
not follow the rules and it just became
this
awful slanging match um with with joe
biden with his eyes closed most of the
time
just absolutely exasperated but we found
some bits and pieces and i was able to
to be on the late night show last night
and um
they're they're tremendously supportive
and yeah i'm really enjoying that
well we love you here at sky and we
always avoid when we come into the
office and when you post something here
we say oh no there's another one that's
up it's up so we all rushed to our
computers to see
so thank you we very much appreciate
your work it's great to talk to you
good luck with the book thanks